jose or keaney will take the mound today
for the houston astros
back after that brief injury list stint
eight starts this season very good
numbers 3.22 era
a little bit of an issue with that
shoulder but was on that il for a short
amount of time and it's great to see him
back in that rotation for the houston
astros
no one popped high in the air to right
field kyle tucker is there
and he puts it away for out number one
3-1 breaking ball grounded softly right
side coming in the field it is d
as he has it and underhands to rakiti
who gets to first in time for the second
out
the one-two to martinez swing and a miss
got him on a high fastball inside
and it's a one-two-three inning for
urquity eduardo rodriguez
is five and three with a 506 that's a
climbing era
he has lost three consecutive decisions
coming off a 6-2 loss
at philly dropping down to bond altoona
he's gonna be a quick out right back to
the pitcher not a good bunt effort at
all
and one man out the 3-2 pitch is
taken outside ball four that was very
close at 94.
it's a one-out base runner for the very
dangerous alex bregman
pounding ball up the middle it's exactly
where they are they flip to zander onto
first and a double play
and that's all for houston hogart's red
sox shortstop
second in the american league and
hitting
ball sent to right field kyle tucker has
a play on it
trips towards the line and puts it away
one out of nobody on for rafael devers
left-handed hitting third baseman swing
and a miss
got him with a 94 mile an hour fastball
second strikeout for
keaty he's retired the first five here
comes
danny santana switch hitting first
baseman swing and a mess got him on the
changeup good morning good afternoon and
good night danny santana
jose or katie has set down the first six
batters he's faced striking out three of
them
here's carlos correa and he has been an
on base machine the last few games
up the middle correa success continues
recently
and against rodriguez on base yet again
so correa aboard for kyle tucker
tucker into right field that ball
falling quickly it'll be in front of
renfro
kicks it a little bit now he runs past
it correa bluffing ago
and now the ball gets away from bogart
it's all kinds of stuff happening
wow base hit for tucker and they're
runners at first and second for lebanese
diaz
there's a ball in the center field
correa is going to read this is down he
heads to third
played quickly in by [ __ ] hernandez so
holding up at third will be correa
three consecutive hits against eduardo
rodriguez
and the astros have loaded up the bases
but now taylor jones
gets the opportunity jones sends one to
right field pretty well hit renfro back
he's near the wall he puts it away but
in comes correa he can trot home
sacrifice fly by taylor jones tucker
moves to third
it's a one nothing game so now runners
at the corners in one out astros with
the one nothing lead and miles straw to
the plate
bouncing ball right side to his left
coming again gonzales he field
and he throws to first to get the out
now they have diaz in a rundown as he
will be tagged out
the run scores however as tucker comes
home a smart play by diaz
the astros pick up another run marvin
gonzalez the 32 year old switch hitter
here's the one two ah speed got him
strike three and gonzales goes down on
strikes that's four for urquity now
two-nothing astros martine maldonado
will lead things off against eduardo
rodriguez
there's a liner up the middle and that's
a base hit for maldonado
a clean single and the astros get the
lead off man aboard
altube tried to bun his way on and
bunted too close to the pitcher as last
time
up here's the pitch hit well left field
high and deep get up and it's out of
here
off the wall in left field and bounced
over
altuve with a two-run jack the astros
lead four to nothing
but that pitch is supposed to be down
and away and he actually hit that outer
quadrant
but altuve with a change up at 88 you
could see that lower half really opened
up but it was a strength of that top
hand
that actually forced that ball out down
the line unfortunately he did hook it
that must have hit the railing and not
the top of the wall
that exit velocity is not going to
impress anybody 92.2
hurts and here is chas mccormicks 2-2 to
mccormick swinging a miss for strike
three
bregman hit into a double play in the
first inning again eduardo's trying to
snap a three-game losing skid for
himself
and that's in there for strike three two
down in here now carlos grid
off speed did he go so what a strange
inning he gives up
that two run homer to a tuba and that
strikes out in the next three
kk hernandez their lead off man these
things offer kitty nine up nine down so
far
four strikeouts there's a swing and a
miss a tip foul into the catcher's glove
five strikeouts for irkidi and there's
one away that'll bring up alex ferdugo
who ground it out here's the pitch
swing and a mess fastball and rakiti is
dominating these red sox hitters mostly
with fastballs but he's mixing in his of
other pitches enough
to continue to make that fastball
effective he looks great
never struck out his first timer kitty
has struck out six and walked one hasn't
allowed a hit through four the one-two
swing and a miss got him on a high
fastball
that's seven strikeouts for urquini
christian vasquez bounced to shortstop
his first time
and a slicer that's well hit to the
corner red sox
finally have one here as that skips up
into the stands
and that'll be an automatic double their
first hit
of the day off urkini it's a double
gonna be martine maldonado in the top of
the order here's the pitch
liner oh nice play here by never's up
and throwing and got him at first base
little spin move there by raffy as well
oh my goodness that's as good as it gets
there by rappy
ball in the hole it's like a cat ball
sharply hit one up picks it behind him
a little dance gets up throws him out
right hander brewer will face correa
tuvay on second bregman on first
and he draws another walk carlos correa
continues to be an on base machine
tucker
two up and the bases loaded tucker has
the most rbis of anybody
in the lineup second on the team to
julie guriel
that ball sharply hit off the glove of
marwing
of the shortstop bogarts into center
field two runs will score
kyle tucker two rbi base hit and the
astros lead this game
six to nothing and that is exactly what
you need
and kyle tucker has been supplying that
big hit frequently here in may
especially at minute maid park
radugo to climb in alex over two red sox
have two hits today
against jose or kitty he'll hammer that
the other way
headed back to the wall mccormick leaps
up can't get it here comes the run in
renfro to score and taking his place at
second is verdugo
with an rbi double and a red sox score
to make it six to one
now it's jd martinez swinging a miss got
him with the breaking ball the slider
for strikeout number eight season high
total for jose or kitty two away
they're gonna let her kitty finish this
six no matter what it appears
3-2 swing and a miss got him on a
fastball inside
jose or katie gets his ninth strikeout
and strands a runner
base is loaded for bregman 0 for two
with a walk and a run
first pitch ground ball through the
right side of base hit
straw scores altuve around third and
coming home
and altuve is in as well it's a throw to
third not in time to get mccormick
a two-run single for bregman and an
eight-to-one astros lead
eight to one still traffic on here in
the bottom of the sixth inning with two
out
new pitcher for the red sox is the
right-hander phillips valdez
correa line drive base hit the left
field mccormick will score
bregman will head to third correa into
second
rbi double by carlos it is 9-1 astros
and now it's tucker who is two for three
with a two run single and a run scored
this ball into center field hernandez on
the move still coming and that ball is
gonna drop in
one run scores correa will score a four
rbi game for kyle tucker
and this game is now 11-1 under retro
with a double tonight
he's gone one for two and has scored the
only red sox run
who made postseason last year he leans
into this one
high fly ball traveling deep to left
field
and hit that ball out of here home run
for hunter renfro number seven
so he's had a good day he may be by
himself in that but he has
eleven to two astros lead the red sox
ninth inning devaldo rodriguez second
inning of relief
rodriguez with the 2-0 and that's a
ground ball hit sharply
sliding to his left on one knee garcia
he fields and throws out santana
and that is the ball game the houston
astros when they're second in a row
defeating the red sox 11-2